positive word of mouth about Marvel's
upcoming Echo TV series is reverberating
all of social media thanks to an intense
first trailer fans can't get enough of
but how does echko fit into the MCU
phases four and five of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe have been full of big
risks and huge swings from the sitcom
antics of w division to the quantum
escapades of Ant-Man and the was quantum
Mania while these projects have seen
mixed reactions from critics One Thing
Marvel fans are eager for is a movie or
series that surprises them though it may
not be the most highly anticipated
Marvel miniseries in the past few years
Ekko might be the one to pull back
skeptical audience members Echo centers
on Maya Lopez the de tracksuit Mafia
leader played by aaka Cox who first
appeared in 2021s Hawkeye series on
Disney plus it's revealed in the show's
finale that Lopez is also the surrogate
daughter of Wilson Fisk AKA kingpen
played by Vincent denafo in a reprisal
of his role from the Netflix Daredevil
series Cox and denaa return in echko
coming January 2024 to Disney plus and
Hulu which will also feature Charlie Cox
returning to the mantle of Daredevil
after appearances in Spider-Man no way
home and She-Hulk attorney at law based
on the first teasers for Ekko the show
looks to be the most brutal and
action-packed series the MCU has had to
offer so far garnering a tvma
rating who's the
monster if you're interested in checking
this series out but don't want to watch
over 120 hours of Marvel content
released since Iron Man here's the basic
rundown of what you'll need to know to
head into Maya Lopez's solo Adventure in
the third episode of Hawkeye titled
Echoes Maya Lopez's backstory is
revealed despite being a deaf child Maya
attended a regular school in 2007 where
she adapted to the environment by
learning to read lips although she faces
discrimination from her teacher she
excels in her studies anyway at home
it's revealed that Maya is the daughter
of William Lopez leader of the tracksuit
Mafia in New York City Maya asks her
father why she's not going to a school
for hearing impaired children and her
father responds by telling her that
though they can't afford to send her to
a deaf School Maya will be stronger for
having to adapt to her deafness and jump
Between Worlds later on William enrolls
his daughter in karate classes which is
where Maya learns to fight and befriends
kazzy who later Becomes Her closest
Confidant in the tracksuit Mafia here
she learns from her father the
strategies for facing opponents who are
much bigger than her remember for your
match it's more about speed than size it
was around the same time as Maya
struggles in school that she became
acquainted with a very important figure
in the street level goings on of the
Marvel Universe in a deleted scene from
Hawkeye it's confirmed that Maya is
picked up from karate class by Wilson
Fisk although Marvel fans no Fisk as the
ruthless antagonist to Heroes like
Daredevil and Spider-Man to Maya he was
a kind Uncle figure who offers to take
her for ice cream as it turns out Fisk
was business partners with William Lopez
and became a leader of the tracksuit
Mafia in New York City prior to the
antagonist appearances in the Netflix
Daredevil series Fisk also carried out
other criminal activities such as being
a lone shark to figures like Derek
Bishop the father of Kate Bishop but
Derrick's death in the Battle of New
York resulted in Kate's mother Elanor
having to work for Fisk to pay off her
late husband's debt Maya's growing up
with Fisk as a close figure will also
play a major role in Ekko as indicated
by the first trailer for the series
which showcases a scene where Maya is
rudely discriminated against for her
deafness by a New York City street
vendor in retaliation Fisk drags the
street vendor into an alley and beats
him to a bloody pulp which Maya
unfortunately Witnesses I see everything
that you
are Ekko will also feature an appearance
from Charlie Cox as Matt Murdoch the
blind New York City City lawyer who
moonlights as the Vigilante Daredevil as
revealed in the Netflix Daredevil series
Murdoch was blinded as a child due to a
chemical truck accident later learning
how to defend himself thanks to a blind
martial artist he befriends named stick
later Murdoch meets fellow law student
foggy Nelson at Columbia University and
the two enter into a legal practice
together but as Murdoch begins to view
the law as not enough to protect the
people of New York City he begins
wearing a mask becomes a vigilante crime
fighter Murdoch's vigilantism eventually
attracts the attention of Wilson Fisk
and the two become adversaries as
Murdoch seeks Vengeance against Fisk for
his numerous criminal Enterprises
Murdoch eventually adopts the superhero
moniker Daredevil complete with a maroon
outfit and defeats Wilson Fisk in combat
turning him into the NYPD the Marvel
Cinematic Universe changed for good with
2018 Avengers Infinity War thanos's
genocide or the snap as it would be
later referred to resulted in massive
changes all across the universe
especially on Earth those changes are
explored in many of the MCU projects
post Avengers endgame the snap
particularly leads to an increase in
organized crime including Wilson fisk's
tracksuit Mafia in New York City and
underground Yakuza in Tokyo as a
survivor of the snap Fisk continues to
reign as a criminal Overlord in New York
City and returns to nearly the level he
was at before Matt Murdoch began his
crime fighting career as Daredevil this
eventually leads to Wilson fisk's
involvement in the Hawkeye series on
Disney plus as well as a major moment in
May Lopez's origin story after Clint
Barton AKA Hawkeye loses his entire
family to the snap he sets out on a
Revenge quest to take down crime
syndicates that had survived believing
them to be less deserving of life than
his own family Barton adopts a new
superhero moniker Ronin and begins
wearing a masked ninja outfit and
wielding dual katana does though his
activity taking down the Mexican cartel
eventually Garners the attention of the
Avengers in Avengers endgame Barton
string of massacres is stopped when
Natasha Romanov AKA Black Widow recruits
him to help the Avengers travel through
time collect the six Infinity Stones and
potentially reverse the snap buron fails
to stop romanof from sacrificing herself
to retrieve the Soul Stone which becomes
a major narrative point in Hawkeye
though in that series Barton also sees
his activ as Ronin come back to haunt
him as revealed in Hawkeye Barton as
Ronin took Vengeance on the tracksuit
Mafia in New York City mercilessly
slaughtering them all Maya Lopez
eventually walked in on the massacre
just as Ronin was leaving and held her
Father William Lopez as he died of his
wounds with William gone Kingpin assumed
control of the tracksuit Mafia while
Maya became his top Commander Ronin
becomes the tracksuit mafia's primary
target following the massacre of William
Lopez and is gang though Clint Barton
hangs up the costume upon rejoining the
Avengers that didn't stop the Ronin
costume and its weapons from being sold
on the black market after which it was
stolen by college student Kate Bishop an
admirer of Hawkeye secretly
investigating her mother's fiance Jack
Duan although Kate is unaware of her
mother's involvement with the tracksuit
Mafia she is hunted by their members
after Dawning the Ronin outfit and
fighting them alerted of potential Ronin
activity Barton tracks Kate down and
steals the Ronin costume back but the
tracksuit Mafia is still operating under
the impression that Kate was the face
behind the mask Barton visits the
tracksuit Mafia to clear her name
although he and Kate end up captives of
Maya Lopez and her right-hand man kazy
unfortunately for Hawkeye Maya doesn't
buy his lie that Ronin was killed by
Natasha Romanov forcing Barton and
Bishop to escape Maia and kazy lose
track of the Archer Duo after they fire
a pin particle Arrow at their truck
destroy destroying it however this
wouldn't be the last confrontation
between the two during the Hawkeye
series after failing to catch Clint
Barton and Kate Bishop Maya Lopez faces
internal conflict with kazy who feels
she's too obsessed with catching the
Ronin however since Maya had stolen a
Rolex watch owned by Barton's wife Laura
which identified her as a shield agent
it's up to Hawkeye himself to stop her
by confronting his past Dawning the
Ronin outfit Barton confronts Maya at
the tracksuit mafia's base of operations
knocking out KY so that he and Maya
could face off one onone Barton
successfully gains the upper hand and
disarms MAA before revealing the truth
about his Massacre of the tracksuit
Mafia
you and I were the same Blinded By The
Rage of his family's death Barton had
accepted a tip from an informant who
wanted William Lopez dead and he reveals
to Maya that the informant had been
instructed to do so by kingpen Maya
initially doesn't believe Barton but
fails to stop Kate Bishop from helping
him Escape against Maya's instincts she
begins to suspect both kazzy and kingpen
for their involvement in her father's
murder Maya requests some time off from
Fisk to clear her head but ends up
heading to Rockefeller Plaza to
intervene in the tracksuit mafia's fight
with the Hawkeye Duo Lopez sadly kills
kazy then later confronts Fisk in an
alley after his encounter with Kate
Bishop as Fisk pleads with Maya for his
life she shoots him another big threat
that could be coming Maya Lope has his
way is the Department of damage control
introduced in Spider-Man no way home as
a governmental entity responsible for
cleaning up superhero's
messes Department of damage control we
have a warrant for the arrest of Peter
Parker led by agent clear the dodc
attempts to prosecute Peter Parker when
his identity as Spider-Man is revealed
however Parker's legal troubles are
solved by Matt Murdoch who also made his
MCU film debut in no way home the
department of damage control plays a
major role in 2022 Disney plus series
Miss Marvel which centers on a jersey
city-based teenager named Kamala Khan
who comes into possession of a magic
bangle that gives her the ability to
create matter out of light a scene in
the finale of Miss Marvel shows a
bulletin board at DOD chq with
photographs of individuals from the
Disney plus MCU shows on it including
Maya Lopez it's hard to make out in the
show itself but official set photos
confirm it this potentially hints at the
department of damage control playing a
role in the Echo series since it's been
confirmed that they're investigating
Maya Charlie Cox's appearance in Ekko as
Matt Murdoch will likely be limited due
to his involvement in his own show
Daredevil born again as well as the
characters other in Universe commitments
as seen in She-Hulk Attorney at Law in
the legal comedy starring Bruce Banner's
cousin Jennifer Walters Murdoch showed
up in Los Angeles to defend Luke
Jacobson a superhero costume designer
against Walter's client and an amateur
superhero known as LeapFrog Murdoch and
Walters later team up in their superhero
personas to help chase down Lea frog
after he kidnaps Jacobson throughout the
adventure they bond over their shared
struggle to balance their legal careers
with the responsibilities of being a
hero that bonding ends up going pretty
well by the end of the episode with
Murdoch and Walters hooking up Murdoch
later joins Walters in a family Barbecue
indicating that their relationship may
continue offc screen with that in mind
it would make since why Murdoch might
not be around Hell's Kitchen for long in
the Echo series as he may be spending
time in Los Angeles with his new
supergirl friend as for rumors about
other MCU TV characters making
appearances in Echo such as the Punisher
and the Defenders time will tell but
they're all connected to Murdoch and
Fisk in one way or another so it just
might
[Music]
happen